quant à monsieur kofi annan il a répondu
à quelques unes de nos questions à
l'instant même
alors qu'il arrivait à l'hôtel crillon
sa résidence parisienne
interrogé par un clip arruazu propose de
l'écouter sur secrétaire général tout à
l'heure le président chirac s'est
entretenu par téléphone avec le
président clinton
ils se sont mis d'accord pour que
l'accord que vous avez en poche puisse
être très vite mise en application que
nous sommes un bon psy mais d'une très
bonne signer ses comptes en banque en se
creusant collège
vous attendiez des discussions
difficiles à new york devant conseil de
sécurité
je ne sais pas comment elles ressemblent
pas ou qu'est ce estime qu'elle est
maintenant gros on venait de signer à
bagdad est très correcte et donc sa
tournée qu'elle même s'il ya des
discussions au conseil de sécurité qu'il
ne veut pas être crues dues au maire
sait jamais donc j'ai demain chez arrive
à new york les mets ma table par
concorde et je vais directement au
bureau tu fais là concédé ce qui évite
un tripot est technique
reid l'accord une zone application
rapidement est ce que ça veut dire que
l'une ce code est prêt à visiter les
hippies en ciel dans l'immédiat puis
déplacée d'un saddam hussein et légumes
en irak a accepté cup on peut visiter
tous les huit des huit années